so as we can see by the heading this
kind of attention is what we call a
compound angle identities and then they
make sense right you're putting more
angles inside here than just one you've
got multiple ones this is a bit of a
mouthful but lucky for you unlike for me
you have this little thing called the
reference sheet which has these
important involved honest I should point
out that just as with everything on the
reference sheet if you're going to the
reference sheet to help you get this
right you are spending time doing that
and that also means you don't know it as
well I would suggest as you use this one
this is the most basic one you're just
started working into your head as we go
through the exercises now this is only
one of them there are actually six there
slashes is a lot but there's a paper
well you already know other right so let
me show you and I will point out by the
way the proof that I just supplied to
you is one of hundreds of troops the
textbook suppliers are slightly
different one that uses of quadrants and
and cosine I intentionally as I point
out before I intentionally try to give
you different ones because that way if
you want you can go back and read them
one in the textbook but this one's a
little bit different now you can use
every one of the compound angle identity
formulas to get to all the rest of them
because all of the trig functions are so
closely linked so here's an example if I
know excited alpha plus beta is how can
I use that to help me work out science
power
- beta is just like Kerrigan books okay
obviously it has to do with just
deciding here but you have to be a
little careful about how you put this on
I'm going to prove it for you not just
show you the result so this is the Sun
this is a difference I'm going to write
the difference as a Sun like what do I
have to add to alpha in order to make it
alpha - video and the answer is if I add
negative beta those are the same you
agreed the reason why this is useful is
because now I can use everything in the
top line right I'm just going to swap
out all the beaters for negative beaters
okay so help yeah I'm gonna write sine
alpha cos what then plus cos alpha sine
in India okay now I can use all the
knowledge I gained from graphi earlier a
couple of weeks ago to help you work out
what to do in this thing okay off on the
side here and which you can offer me a
couple of tiny glass okay now this is a
bit of usual ordinarily we would draw
our graph search traditions from naught
to 360 degrees that's normal isn't it
okay this is just going to be a small
one on the side I actually want us to
draw it not from not too pretty to be
but from negative 360 set 360 is a point
I wanna make so here's what cosine looks
like just have to have a basic one don't
even label anything on I just want the
shape and in addition to that let's do
so and do that one so there it is sorry
cosine from maybe 360 two pieces okay
can you remember if I slap a minus sign
I think this is codec we know what could
happen if I want to work out on the
basis of that what does cause of
negative X look like the my decided of
flipping the it's a reflection right
which way am i reflect is what variable
is being affected
it's the x-ray I see why over here why
is not been touched
okay so only the X and you're flipping
which way is that fitting X's are about
the exact leads that horizontal values
isn't it
so the difference between this and this
is that you take this and you fully fit
around horizontally okay now how do we
get this have a look what happens when
you take this shape like this and then
you flip it around far as upcoming
what's the result there's no change
because it's symmetrical around the y
axis to notice so that these two things
are equal to each other cause of
negative x equals codec so I can
actually write down key R sine alpha I
can just write that as odd makeup and
you can go ahead you can check out your
calculator right cause of 30 is three
driven to positive negative 30 your
calculator will still tell you is route
302 okay have a look at fine this is not
suitable for again I'm going to take
this and like you suggested I'm going to
grab it and I'm going to reflect it
horizontally okay this time I do get
something different
I want you to put it in on the graph
look I'm going to go I'm going to draw
it I always draw a big piece from left
to right that's cool so I'm going to go
from right to left so let's do that
reflection okay so the red one and
that's sine of negative x and the blue
one is just regular scientists like
knowledge now I've put it horizontally
but that's what all I've done but she
knows that there's nothing I could do to
turn the blue graph into the red rap
what's another way that I can get from
blue to red without doing it this way
what else could I do in movie history
okay sure I could shift it by instead of
going like that I could take it and they
just move over a little
I have your patient there's enough here
to do these because they periodic you
can do all kinds of things I could take
it like this right and I can flip it
vertically do you agree like see how
there is this not turn point here and it
sort of pops up to the bottom side here
and this life of the bond goes up on top
does that make you so exactly this
horizontal flip for this function ends
up the same as a vertical flip right how
I write it right if I wanted to take
this guy which is on y equals and
vertically flip it you what would
actually buy I wouldn't do the I would
cut the negative sign on the way in that
vehicle
isn't it so minus y equals sine X which
of course I can write the negative on
the other side if I want y equals minus
sine X you've seen us before we were
graphing this up with you right so now
come back to our identity over here this
side of negative beta I'm going to
rewrite it as negative sine beta okay
by virtue of this transformation concern
in this case do it that way end up being
famously that way all right I'm almost
finished this going out the front I've
already dealt with that negative sign
I'm going to bring it at the front of
that term I'll make it - do you see what
I've done
so the trig identity for sine alpha plus
beta looks like that you should know you
need for sine alpha minus V none only
dip it in one way what is it
conveniently it's just this - like it do
you see that so Sammy's party Lupe's
parallel to a plus or biz - parallel two
months and everything else is the same
when you get triple